oh come on what the [ __ ] just happened
are you ready to see a barky a barky I
mean is this it's a kind of dog barking
for a while no no it's it's not a
cartoon this is not a cartoon it's live
action and these are very popular from
like 1929 for like three or four years
what is it it's called the barky a barky
this one is called the dog way melody
this is just gonna be dogs no I don't
know why you'd think that
now these were critically acclaimed we
have but critics are idiots and critic
you played theaters love them
the people in theaters were idiots to
the smartest persons the lion in 1930
these were voted more popular than
Laurel and Hardy what yeah they're great
there's nothing about this that you
wouldn't like no yes no David
playing piano no oh my god no it's
totally normal Humane Society came down
no they did not
this is the set and they were like this
is no they did not know dogs are being
hurt oh no oh I just can't I don't even
know how it's being done
no yeah go kiss my grandmother God was I
can't they you have a cat that plays
peeing on on YouTube right yeah same
deal the investor this is too much plot
for dogs
[Music]
yeah just their faces are so expressive
oh he's checking out the girl's legs
even the dog producer is a dog pervert
Hollywood's a good town beautiful oh boy
she's gorgeous Dave you can't say that
come on Ron I admit the car wants to try
you up oh yes
we're a Laurel and Hardy must have just
been like what do we have to do they're
putting carrots up dogs butts and
they're beating us wait what about the
Bucks and get some gum see that's nice
by the way I do agree they are not ready
from Broadway no what are you talking
about they can sing you think they could
sing kiss my grandma those weird cut
they're some weird everything no no any
cut and this is a good cut Oh what's
where would they lick their mouth it's
all weird no just when they lick them
it's weird when it starts it's a great
hat that guy does look like he's pretty
well put together dog should wear hats
Oh God
can't you just picture just a theater
full of dumb asses it's like everything
you want it's like Wilbur watching a
prop comic oh god we know what he's
gonna do what are they of like strings
on him no they're hopping you know
they're not hopping or hopping no okay
night oh she got the job
oh good cuz I was really invested in her
story 8:15 I wasn't just worried about
the sanity of the dogs by the way if
it's opening night you're still
hammering there's problems these guys
should be capitalists oh that look
normal that looked like they were
definitely lifting it for sure there's
where they make the costumes
oh no they're oh my god no no no no no
oh no oh god what what are you saying
what for haven't you seen this yeah but
I get upset by it
Showtime knock first you perv Oh see he
was gonna stop buying actors awkward
yeah there's a love triangle happening
oh oh he's propped up by anything else
it is absolutely propped up by zero
absolutely
dock near the Sultan's place the
Sultan's harem they're making fun of an
actual Broadway play at the time like
what the hell is happening I mean this
is you see how that dog spit it out as a
yeah so the Sultan this is the Sultan
how am i watching this is what dogs do
Oh hold of him Bo's on my hair oh oh
whoa him buddy whoa whoa yep let's get
some bimbos in here
he means bimbo like bimbos a literal
boatload yeah these ladies tie my lady
dumb ladies yeah bimbos those dogs tell
ya it's [ __ ] I should have been an
act of myself
Oh God that's not good camera work maybe
a dog was doing hello oh good the first
acts over okay so now he's just kind of
created a he's got a bunch of tortured
slaves yeah this is like the beginning
of taken but with dogs he's smoking a
hookah yeah the happiest that dogs been
and that one's got a prong and that one
doesn't know how to put its jewelry out
of her [ __ ] mind that one's like 80
yeah that's no lady ow
no stings that dog is just like whatever
yeah these dogs you got the good job
yeah that is as comfy as a dog gets what
are they humans are dogs the dogs Dave
you know what's awful as I'm starting to
like get its charm how about some music
[Music]
this also bizarre and awful this is
absolutely the are appropriate it's
exploitative to both dogs and sexually
exploitive and culturally inappropriate
oh it's on a lot of levels wrong what is
that the wheel of I don't want to know
look come on what the [ __ ] just happened
well they just oh yeah no yes
we've got a pillow shag Rock in sex time
they have a smush room yeah they're
gonna get it on oh and the dogs like
that's great haebang enjoys it no no no
what's wrong no I just thought we saw
the worst usually popular Al Jolson I
can't oh no what are they gonna do see
it's not that bad what's wrong it's
insane it's just they're just like we'll
get a black dog it'll be fine
it's perfectly with human hands that's
not his real paws by the way thanks yeah
they should explain the hands
positioning that I need an explanation
on is the hands everything else makes
sense there he goes oh my god someone
like it sometimes yeah of course there's
even some racist dogs there how many
scenes are in this one forty nine oh my
god turn the award oh good I was just
hoping to see a dog birth I'm sleepy too
that's the easiest shot to get didn't
make it how much hey suffering yeah well
of course he's the guy he's got away
lots of notes but that baby's gonna come
out like a dog right quick nurse
let me see their deal little faces oh
boy oh my god oh of course they walk on
all fours at times when they're upset
yes they loved it
of course they did not that good oh
thank god I've never been so excited to
see finale that Golden Retriever had a
pretty easy gig yeah
how did they do this I mean these dogs
must have been like hey you know we're
dogs right lutely just wrap tape around
them yeah they just taped three dogs
together and then just put a hose on no
words what's happening this is hard to
take there's a train now motion picture
news called this ace high an
entertainment yeah
ace high yeah also ace high and torture
I mean you can't stop these dogs from
yawning every shot that you hoped for
longer 20 seconds one of them is like
I'm beat Tom Daly said it was one of the
best short subjects ever made well they
need to go away
think of these dogs right now look Jesus
please please please please stop please
I don't even want to know how that's
done that's awful what are they doing
they have them tied together with
raincoats why what the [ __ ]
oh that's nice
I mean he's got a good voice the cool
thing is you know these dogs were
treated well absolutely I mean I just
hope the dog Critics Association like
said were they ready for opening night
they give it a boat yeah good love it
they love it
oh great show my darling what the only
reason that it would be wrong for this
dog to say yes is because she's getting
a part dart breakers dart breaks oh oh
no I don't want to know how much hot
sauce had to go in there for God's eyes
[Applause]
she's so poor so torn
very spazzy breakup now finally
something I can relate to this isn't
weird oh god how please do not show I'm
trying to drink it guys got one ah thank
God guys are shit-faced yeah the dogs
and they've had a bottle he's just upset
yeah he's crying two losses go oh and
it's Thanksgiving card cottage
Thanksgiving house so this is her date
oh yeah yeah you made it pretty clear
it's for you no yeah whoo he copped a
feel yeah
he grabbed a little dog I felt a little
stumbling she's had a couple of hope
she's not driving he's not gonna give up
no they never do he's a Hollywood
producer I got him go it looks so normal
look baby she's checking out her boobs
he's closing the door oh I didn't know
dogs could do that oh God this is normal
it'll get ya oh Jesus
holy [ __ ] this is brett ratner dog oh my
god oh god I can't believe that they are
what is happening guys
what stops Martin look at her face Jesus
Christ and what he's just got some sweet
pockets got a magic bottle
he's Nostradamus through oh here he goes
that's the only normal dog we've seen
the one lying on the couch yeah that dog
is nor mine that little one that fell
but oh my God he's good dude please and
this they were waiting for that yeah
that's the happiest those dogs have been
[Music]
shouldn'ta raped
what a great story well what how did
that happen I might have a hard time
forgetting that how many crew members
shot themselves oh 78 look if you can't
get the dog to juggle we might have to
go in another direction he's like I'm
gonna go to my Oldsmobile real quick
well that was insane awful yeah so many
levels of awful yep that was the worst
thing we've seen yes in a world of worst
that was it might stop coming over your
house
oh yeah